FELIPE HOFFA: With over
500 sessions at Next '19,
it's understandable that you
might have not seen them all.
So if you missed Modern Data
Warehouse with BigQuery,
where the BigQuery lead
Jordan Tigani shares how
we are transforming
BigQuery into the data
warehouse of the
future, don't worry,
because this is a rewind.
You might already know that
BigQuery is our enterprise data
warehouse built for the cloud.
It can easily store
exabyte of data,
as well as run frequent
queries over petabytes of it.
Everything is encrypted,
durable, and highly available.
And these are some
of the features that
make BigQuery really unique.
It's fully managed
and serverless.
It handles streaming data to
provide real time analytics.
It has built in
support for machine
learning and G analysis.
And high speed
in-memory BI engine
was just added for instant
interactive dashboards.
And of course,
during the talk we
had quotes from industry
analysts and customers
that can attest to all of
this, as well as petabyte scale
interactive demos.
But let's focus on the
main message of this talk.
How is Google Cloud
putting all of this
together to build
our vision of what
a data warehouse of the
future should look like?
Let's start with the
first two elements.
A data warehouse should
handle storage and compute.
And by that, I mean
the ability to collect
all the data you
need to have together
and the ability to analyze it
and combine it at any scale.
In fact, one of our customers is
storing more than 250 petabytes
of data in BigQuery.
And others have
run a single query
over more than 5 petabytes.
To pull this off, you really
want your data warehouse
to be truly serverless.
You get to decide on
your data and the queries
you want to run on it, while we
take care of running everything
else behind the scenes.
And what's the magic
behind the scenes?
BigQuery's architecture
that separates storage
from compute and a petabyte
network connecting both sides.
Cool!
But that's not enough.
A modern data
warehouse should be
able to work with
real time data.
To prove this during the talk,
Jordan ran a dataflow pipeline,
generating data out
of more than 600 CPUs.
As you can see here,
these nodes were
generating more than 2
gigabytes of data per second.
And he showed how BigQuery
was able to instantly run
queries and find patterns
over this incoming data.
What else do you expect from
a modern data warehouse?
Centralized storage.
And this is something
new with BigQuery.
We already know that BigQuery
can store all of your data
and analyze it.
But what if we want to
read it from other systems?
BI tools, Batch and Stream
processors, Hadoop, Spark,
machine learning
platforms, they should all
be able to read data
storage BigQuery.
And we just announced
that BigQuery stores
API to enable fast parallel
rates without the need
of exporting data first.
What else?
Security the trust.
To make sure we can put BigQuery
into the hands of our most
sensitive customers, Google has
developed features with them,
like customer managed encryption
keys and access transparency.
If anyone managing your
cloud data warehouse
has to look at your
data, you should know
when and why this happened.
And you get that with BigQuery.
Next, data sharing.
You want to make BigQuery
available to anyone
that needs to analyze
data in your organization.
On one hand, we have a
strong permission model.
But we also want
to make the power
of data accessible
to those who need it.
So with BigQuery, you
can save and share
queries, as well as data sets.
And your analyst can
create beautiful reports
with Data Studio and
third party tools.
And to make all of these
reports fast and scalable,
BI Engine is a new block that
acts as a transparent catch in
between, an in-memory database
that knows when to bring data
from the back end,
where you only
need to decide how much
memory you want it to have.
And we're making BigQuery
increasingly accessible,
even to users that would rather
do everything in a spreadsheet.
And the last bit of a modern
data warehouse, predictive.
With infinite storage, you can
know what happened in the past.
With real time
streaming data, you
can tell what's happening now.
And with machine
learning capabilities,
you can predict what
will happen next.
Now BigQuery saved room
to create and run machine
learning models
natively, inside.
Yes, you can create
a model and then
use it to predict,
within BigQuery and only
using a couple SQL commands.
To the initial linear and
logistic regression models,
Google has added [INAUDIBLE]
clustering, and matrix
factorization, and
even the ability
to import any TensorFlow model
you created outside BigQuery,
and even trained
TensorFlow models
without leaving your
favorite data warehouse.
This is our vision of a
modern data warehouse.
But it doesn't stop here.
Take the full talk to see
how one of our customers
puts everything
together to power
the future, driverless cars.
That's it for now.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
Now it's your turn
to try BigQuery.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, and
remember to subscribe.